Americans by and large have no idea that
crime rates in the US have been
plummeting since the nineteen nineties
the murder and violent crime rates have
dropped by more than fifty percent
there's a new Vox morning consult poll
which talk to two thousand registered
voters about their perceptions on crime
in their neighborhoods and more broadly
in America and nearly seventy percent of
us voters think that there is more crime
in the US now than there was two decades
ago forty-three percent of those saying
that there is much more crime now than
there was two decades ago this includes
violent crime this includes drug crime
theft white-collar crime etc the reality
is fortunately that the crime rate in
the United States has dropped
drastically over the last 20 years why
is this relevant it's relevant because
of what I'm about to show you involving
Newt Gingrich talking about the issue
insisting that people feel that things
are more violent so we should I guess
pretend that they are violent crime is
down the economy it's done it is not
down in the biggest cities violent crime
murder rate is down how come how come
it's up in Chicago up in Baltimore
washing Hockett swear certain certainly
we're not time capital your third a
third biggest city violent crime across
the country is down the average American
i will bet you this morning does not
think crime is down does not think they
are safer but it is we are safer and it
is no no that's your view I just don't
know either I said well what if she
doesn't know what I says also affect
current view is that liberals have a
whole set of statistics which
theoretically may be right but it's not
working beings it but what you're saying
it hold on that mr. speaker because
you're saying liberals use these numbers
they use this sort of magic that this is
the FBI statistics they're not a liberal
organization there but I should is
equally true people feel it more threats
they feel it but the facts don't support
it as a political candidate I'll go with
how people feel and you go with a
theoretician yeah she'll go with the
facts so guys I mean this is this is
really important because if people feel
that crime is higher than it is
authoritarian candidates like Donald
Trump who make all sorts of ludicrous
proclamations about crime are going to
be seen more favorably if you
understand that crime is down
drastically in 20 years you are less
likely to get sucked in by the Trump
rhetoric I think a lot of people Rachel
see this and think it's just funny it is
funny but it has real-world impacts that
are really scary he is trying to
capitalize on kind of this certain
spikes in cities of homicides shootings
that get substantial media coverage
especially with certain attached social
movements so he's trying to capitalize
that on this this nation that's beset
with crime and it needs that needs him
to repair it so that I think if you can
recognize that difference then you will
kind of understand what he's saying is
completely inaccurate when I hear that
people think crime is much higher than
it is I say well we need to educate the
people Newt Gingrich hears that people
think crime is much higher than it is
and he says well we should just pretend
that they're right and design our
campaigns around what we would do
assuming that that's true even though it
isn't really really disturbing way
forward if you ask me why not educate
rather than continue to allow people to
believe these things and further distort
what the path forward is based on
authoritarian ideas around non-existent
increasing crime rates